next up with chef week
how about pronounce ed okay Evan I love
you thank you bro your content is
awesome your aim is noble but as a fan I
feel obligated to tell you that you're
pumping up too much new content too
quickly I try to watch all your stuff
you upload but I'm having a hard time
keeping up now so first of all I really
appreciate the love I appreciate the
feedback
I love it when you guys try to give me
suggestions on what to do here's the
thing I don't see myself as a show it's
Channel and I've talked about this
number of times on the channel my aim is
to produce a lot of content that can
help you grow my aim is not just to
produce one video a week my aim is to
provide lots of different content where
you can learn from all the successful
people and I don't need you to watch
every video if you see a video on my
channel that doesn't interest you that
you don't like the topic you don't you
know then that place right now where you
need to learn that that's totally cool
just like you don't turn on CNN or you
know CNBC or HGTV or whatever television
station and expect to watch every single
episode of every single show that they
air right I think too many people are
restricted in their view I also want to
make sure that you take an action like I
would much rather you watch one video a
week and take action and go improve your
life and make a big change
then sit there in front of YouTube all
day long right that's not my goal so
have you just watching videos all day
long I need you to go and do something
that's what drives me at the same time I
don't know that people invest enough in
themselves the content that I'm putting
out especially you look at the top 10
series in the belief life series in the
mentor Me series we're spending time to
go through hours and hours and hours of
footage to find the very best you look
at an Elon Musk's top 10 video as an
example how many interviews has he done
how many speeches has he done how many
videos are there out there of him we
take all of that condense it into one
video for you that maybe 10 minutes
maybe 15 minutes maybe 20 minutes maybe
25 minutes the best that he's ever said
on camera we combine and put together
for you that's an insane opportunity
that's what
I wanted for me selfishly it's why I
wanted to share it with you guys and
thankfully you enjoy you're consuming it
too and sharing it and I sincerely
appreciate that but if you're not the
time to to watch that and digest it and
learn from these successful
entrepreneurs honestly I feel like you
need to make the time like the
leadership people on my team I make them
watch the top ten videos every day every
morning it's part of the process I need
you to be exposed to greater things
because if all you're doing is the
day-to-day stuff and you never expose to
the things that can make you go bigger
then you're never going to grow then all
the creativity and all the big ideas are
only going to come from me and I don't
want that I need you to grow as a human
being and you don't get enough of that
from the people in your life and so
that's why I create these videos to push
you and challenge you so one if you
don't have the time cool you know I
don't need you to watch every video most
important for me is that you are
watching videos in your and you're
having an impact you're changing
something at the same time though I'm
not asking for a lot like what's the
total amount of time of all the videos
that I put up on a daily basis 30
minutes 40 minutes like how much time
are you spending watching TV you spend
30 40 minutes watching TV a day what are
the other activities that you're doing I
would say that watching my videos for 30
or 40 minutes a day it's a single most
most impactful thing in terms of a
resource you could inject in your head
period that exists period and if you
don't want to make that investment in
yourself that's on you so I have no
intention of slowing down I have no
intention of going to one video a day or
one video week or a couple times a week
if you can't keep up totally cool
totally appreciate that I appreciate
your viewership below with you for the
videos that you do watch and I hope you
take action but I'm a channel I'm not a
show and everything that I put out is
quality and can change your life that's
why I do it
so hopefully that explains it